oh
[Music]
when it rains pseudoscience it [ __ ]
pours
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
now i'm shooting a pickup here outside
of my studio so
i can tell you about my sponsor babel so
i know
a lot of us have tried to utilize this
past year or so to learn
a new skill and learning a new language
has always been a goal of mine so babel
is this awesome language app that i
discovered that teaches you a new
language
in as little as three weeks with short
fun and accessible classes they're
taught by real language teachers
not ai technology or algorithms and they
use
real-life situations and dialogue to
make it easier
and more applicable in the real world
university studies have even found that
15 hours of using babel
is equivalent to one whole semester of
college spanish so
it actually does work they've got
podcasts
stories and games to help immerse
yourself in the new language and
they also have live classes as well
so whether you want to learn a new
language for work
travel family or self-improvement in my
honest opinion
babel makes it so much easier to help
you meet that goal
so if you want to get started check out
the link in the description for six
months free when you buy six months
okay over to the studio today we'll be
taking a
deep dive into the controversial book
that has been making
shock waves across wellness spaces and
that is
intuitive fasting by functional medicine
practitioner
dr will cole you know the one that our
girlfriend
gweny was all over online
now before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my general
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
we will be talking a lot about calories
and caloric restriction
so please skip this video if that's not
supportive to your journey
also don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on
a episode all right we got a lot to
unpack
so just let me uh a little energy for
this one
let's dive in so those of you who missed
this controversial instagram post
the goopy queen herself has recently
endorsed this
intuitive fasting book as a flexible
meal plan that combines intuitive eating
intermittent fasting
and the ketotarian diet
yep that apparently is a thing now
despite these seemingly
contradictory eating philosophies
according to
gwen and dr cole intuitive fasting will
not punish or
restrict you but promises to help you
find
food freedom by strengthening your
intuition
through fasting
now if you're a regular viewer of my
channel you probably just heard what i
said
and have asked yourself like i've asked
myself
how much time and energy do i have for
[ __ ]
today one would think not much abby
not much but alas here i am
dragging myself through the trenches for
all of your entertainment
and educational benefits so i love you
you're welcome but the sooner i get into
this the sooner i get to go home
for a cocktail so let's answer the
age-old question
what the [ __ ] is intuitive fasting
according to dr cole intuitive fasting
merges
intermittent fasting and his
questionable version
of intuitive eating to achieve metabolic
flexibility
which he claims to be the root of
wellness so what the hell does metabolic
flexibility mean
anyways well according to cole this is
our body's ability to adapt to different
fuel sources
like carbs and fat by becoming
metabolically flexible
through his four week program coal
claims that it will balance our blood
sugar levels
improve gut health manage stress balance
hormones
reduce inflammation decrease hunger and
sugar cravings
increase weight loss improve longevity
promote anti-aging
etc etc you know the standard list of
ailments that apparently
every diet fixes there must be some kind
of template that these diet gurus just
copy and paste into their marketing
materials but
anyways i digress if your wellness
[ __ ] bingo card isn't already full
he also claims that this mystical
metabolic flexibility achieved through
fasting
is the key to intuitive eating
oh my no no
no no i would
love to know what the creators of
intuitive eating evelyn tripoli and
elise resh
think about that statement right there
and while i don't want to put words in
their mouth
from everything that i know about
intuitive eating as an eating philosophy
any restrictive diet is not and will
never be
an integral key part of intuitive eating
full stop so either dr cole is just
ignoring the defined intuitive eating
principles and making up his own
definition to fit his agenda
or he's co-opting the term because it's
trendy and cool
in the hopes that it will sell more
copies of his book
or both it's obviously both but more on
that later
now the research does suggest that
impaired metabolic flexibility
is linked to obesity diabetes
insulin resistance and metabolic
syndrome but
there's no research to suggest that
there is any specific diet
that would have any measurable impact on
it at all
in fact a recent randomized control
trial found that
putting overweight and obese adults on a
healthy diet
made up of plant-based foods fish and
low-gi carbs
did not even improve metabolic
flexibility and from a crap-ton of
population research
we're pretty confident that this is a
very
healthy dietary pattern for most people
so while the marketing of this diet and
its associated health benefits
might sound super sexy and appealing
because hey
metabolism and flexible are two words
that wellness culture really likes
this theory of his is simply not
evidence-based in terms of intermittent
fasting
as i've talked about in my video right
here there is emerging research
supporting
some health benefits for some folks but
dr cole's allegedly
intuitive version of intermittent
fasting strips it
of a lot of what makes it an attractive
and even potentially intuitive option
for some people
for example traditional intermittent
fasting puts restrictions
only on when you can eat not what you
can eat
meaning that during your eating window
you can eat liberally
without a caloric restriction or
limiting certain foods
but dr cole's version of intermittent
fasting is done in combination
with the ketotarian diet which is
basically a
plant-based version of the keto diet
ironically
he states that he doesn't like to give
hard and fast rules about
what you can and can't eat but then he
goes on to share a list
of allowed foods along with a list of
foods that should be avoided
what the [ __ ] so in case you're curious
let me walk you through what you now
can't eat
on this non-restrictive flexible
meal plan of his that is no sugar
artificial sweeteners gluten unhealthy
fats
meat dairy alcohol plus you'll also need
to severely limit
your fruit starchy vegetables legumes
and grains
in terms of what is allowed dr cole
promotes
clean keto foods which includes cooking
oils
nuts seeds eggs non-starchy veg fish and
plant-based protein
is this guy delusional like
is this guy just hoping that people who
read this don't understand the words on
the page well enough to
catch his gaslighting lies because i am
legit
confused
also his idea of plant-based protein
is somewhat questionable in my books for
example
in his list of plant-based protein he
includes things like broccoli asparagus
avocado brussels sprouts and spinach
all of which provide around two to three
grams of protein per serving
not really my idea of a typical
serving of protein which ideally should
clock in closer to
15 to 25 grams unless you're someone
like gwyneth who
can completely separate your mind from
your body for the sake of
instagramming your next [ __ ] cleanse
who the hell
is going to keep this up with all that
said
let's take a closer look at dr cole's
four-week intuitive fasting plan
starting with week one week one is meant
to
reset the body and establish metabolic
flexibility
by fasting for 12 hours and following a
ketotarian diet
at the end of week 1 dr cole claims that
you should expect to
lose weight decrease inflammation
improve digestion
and decrease sugar cravings and hunger
he also claims that there's no
caloric restriction and that you can eat
to satiety
and that this week serves as an
intuitive and
gentle fasting plan i mean
that is an oxymoron in itself
and i didn't think it would get more
problematic than that but
then he goes on to suggest that he's
still strongly recommends sticking to
his meal plan
because even one small little hard candy
or a few bites of a muffin
can sabotage your progress towards
becoming an efficient
fat burner his words folks not mine
because
obviously i don't talk in black ease
but it is interesting that dr cole will
consistently use words like
gentle intuitive flexible
while in the same breath exercising
fear-mongering tactics
to bully readers into following his meal
plan to a tea
sorry is this based on his
intuition or ours now if we look at a
suggested meal plan
we're only clocking in around 1300 to
1600 calories a day
whereas the general caloric
recommendations for most adults
is actually around 2000 to 2300 calories
a day
in other words you're looking at a major
caloric
deficit on a diet that dr cole promises
is not about caloric restriction
for the love of all that is holy can we
please just make
a little more sense you sound insane
do you realize that anyways moving on to
week two
for the few poor souls who make it this
far
this week is apparently all about
recharging
your metabolism by restoring blood sugar
balance
and improving blood lipid levels i just
want to strongly emphasize
that there is nothing you can do fasting
or otherwise
to reset or recharge your metabolism
dr cool is basically just repackaging
diet culture buzzwords to help sell his
diet program
and it probably is working pretty well
in addition when it comes to blood lipid
levels
it can actually take anywhere from
several weeks to six
months for someone to see an improvement
in their cholesterol from changing their
diet
so to suggest that one week of fasting
is going to give you such
overwhelming positive results is
totally unfair marketing but i digress
in week two the fasting window increases
from 12 hours
to 14 to 18 windows but of course
this is an intuitive fasting plan which
dr
cole's made up definition of intuitive
eating means that there is no specific
time frame
for the fast and that instead you should
just
listen to your body so basically you can
just decide what time you want to start
and end your fast and that supposedly
is to imply that this is all super
intuitive
i mean traditional intermittent fasting
also gives you the option
of when to position your fasting window
and i think that
most people would argue that unless it's
100
aligned with your natural hunger and
fullness cues
which may change from day to day it's
not
intuitive at all dr cole also mentions
that you may
feel irritable hungry restless and
anxious as a result of the lack of carbs
shocker i mean this may be related to
what we call the keto flu
and it's also very common when starting
a very low carb diet
to mediate this he introduces what he
calls
clean carb cycling which means that you
can increase your net carbs to
75 to 150 grams one to two times per
week
now while this amount falls outside the
range of what's typically recommended
for
the keto diet it is still considered a
pretty low carb diet not to mention the
meal plan is
very low in calories despite introducing
a slight increase in carbs
also if you want to talk about listening
to your body
if you're feeling fatigued low energy
cranky and most importantly hungry
that's a pretty clear indication
that you're just not eating enough and
any fasting continuous caloric
restriction
or carb cycling in a major caloric
deficit
is not going to solve that problem so to
brand this meal plan
as one that is free from punishment and
restriction
is downright deceiving as [ __ ] but
unfortunately
it actually gets worse week three
involves extending your fast to 20 to 22
hours
every other day meaning you only have
a two to four hour eating window three
days of the week
and you get a 12 hour eating window the
remaining four days
uh thanks apparently popping in these
enhanced fasts
helps to reduce the risk of disease
increase longevity
improve chronic disease symptoms
increase cellular renewal
and increase stem cells so again
lots of buzzy buzzy bs words that people
want to hear
but is there any science to back them up
well sure if you're an animal or a cell
in a petri dish
because that is what dr cole relies on
to substantiate his claims
the few human studies that he does cite
were very short-term studies
on intermittent fasting alone and not
on his bs frankenstein of various diets
so to continuously make such bold claims
about these
long-term outcomes like disease
prevention with no
long-term research to back them up is
again
grossly misleading now finally we've
arrived at
week four which involves transitioning
back to a 12-hour fasting window
and working in two to four clean carb
days
so same same but different
even though by week four you're
permitted a longer eating window
the meal plan is still crazy restrictive
and punishing
ironically the major focus of week four
is to
cultivate a healthier relationship with
food by
practicing mindfulness and this my
friends
is where i have to go off here's how dr
cole defines
mindfulness in his book maybe you're in
your fasting window but you're dying for
a cookie
or maybe you just ate your break a fast
meal
but you're still feeling hungry whatever
the situation
step back and take a few deep breaths
maybe make yourself a cup of tea and
while you sip it
observe any thoughts and emotions that
come up
notice any urges that you have to eat or
indulge in certain foods
and then that's it you don't have to do
anything about those emotions or urges
other than notice them with no judgments
or resistance
this is how you grow your mindfulness
muscle which
helps you get yourself back into the
present moment
and connect with your intuition
so mindfulness to cool is
hearing your body scream for more
nourishment
and then actively ignoring it by getting
yourself
a cup of tea this is the same
problematic pro ed
diet culture tips that we've been fed
since
i was a little girl want that cupcake
eat celery instead
craving chocolate go brush your teeth
want some chips
just drink a gallon of water will
yourself through using your mind power
to not be hungry no
no no no no no amount of deep breaths
is going to change the fact that your
body needs
energy to sustain itself and the longer
and more fiercely that you restrict
the more likely you are to crack and
become completely
out of control with food and while i do
appreciate that dr cole provides a
very small disclaimer that individuals
with a history of disordered eating
should not follow this diet plan while
also mildly acknowledging that
disordered eating
can be triggered by fasting he still
insists that
his plan is not disordered eating
disguised as a wellness practice
i mean it's similar to the way that he
insists that his meal plan is
not restrictive yet he admits that
you're likely to feel hungry
and fatigued on it and that you should
eat what you want
oh but you will face grave danger if you
don't do it his way to a tee
honestly the kind of mental gymnastics
going on here
is highly manipulative and just straight
up dangerous
what's worse is that he claims that
eliminating foods during the plan
is not a way to punish your body but a
way to show yourself
honor and respect
so in other words he's saying that
starving yourself
and denying your hunger is a form of
self-love friends this is
all kinds of effed up and it really does
encourage an extremely dysfunctional
relationship with food there is nothing
intuitive about denying your body food
when it's
begging to be fed or for following a
bunch of bogus food rules in the name of
wellness here's the thing intuitive
eating
is not a weight loss diet and we need
to stop seeing wellness influencers or
experts trying to
co-opt this language to fit a
restrictive agenda
can you lose weight while practicing
intuitive eating maybe
some folks will naturally definitely
lose weight
can you try to actively lose weight
through intermittent fasting
while also doing intuitive eating maybe
like yes and no as it was originally
conceptualized
intuitive eating wasn't a weight loss
diet
but i don't think that all the
principles are for everyone in its
entirety
so i do think that if your goal is to
lose weight
however that may be you can still
incorporate
some of the key principles of intuitive
eating into your plan
so things like respecting your body and
gentle nutrition
i will also say that some people
naturally
and intuitively eat in a shortened
eating window
that's what feels intuitive and good to
them so
that's great but it really does come
down to intention
when you pile restriction onto
restriction cutting out foods that you
love
and abstaining for 22 hours from food
even when your body wants it and then
have to drink some tea to distract
yourself from your hunger cues
that my friends could not be farther
from an intuitive life
obviously dr cole or dr cole's publicist
and publisher and by proxy the bull
queen guadal paltrow
are simply jumping on the intuitive
eating bandwagon because
it's trendy it's cool and diet
has become a bit of a dirty word talking
about weight loss is now
a hell of a lot less sexy than talking
about digestion
and energy levels and generally how we
feel
but man if you're gonna write a whole
book about an eating philosophy
at least pick up a copy and do some
homework you can't just throw around
words like intuitive
food peace and food freedom next to
things like clean
detox ketotarian 22-hour fast
oh and here are some tips to help
suppress your hunger cues cole
and paltrow do not belong in this space
[Music]
so if the gweny endorsement wasn't
enough to steer you away from this book
the problematic dangerous manipulative
advice
from the book that i presented to you
right now
hopefully will and folks that is all
that i have for you guys today
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below about what
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you